Can you go over COVID supplementation recommendations that folks could have on hand, I presume, over the winter.
So most of the people listening to this are already taking a lot of immune supplements.
You're already taking vitamin C and zinc and vitamin D, you know, things that we have in our clear CV, which was created solely for COVID.
I never recommend that for cancer patients because you're already taking everything that's in that.
So that's, that's the biggest thing. So ever COVID is a virus and viruses and flu viruses and things that are going to be happening in the next several months can really bring you down.
And so you what do you do for a virus? Well, you guys have one of the best things for a virus sitting in your home. It's called a right machine.
So make sure you run the right programs for COVID. Make sure you run the right viral programs if you feel like you're coming down with something.
Certainly you could up your immune stimulants if you feel like you're coming down with something.
I have several blog posts about different things you could do for viruses. So look that up as well.
Our clear CV product for other family members can be really beneficial because it has all the different things in it for viruses.
We're actually going to be reformulating that the next couple months, adding vitamin A to that as well.
So that's a good product to use. Any of your mushroom products are really good for COVID.
Now, if you're exposed to truly isn't COVID, no problem is if you go and get a COVID test, those are so blasted, you're relevant to this point.
And they're absolutely completely inaccurate. So to me, it's not worth doing it. It's never worth doing a COVID test. I never would have ever, you know, they would have had to put a gun to my head before I would have got a COVID test.
So it's I don't think they're good tests.
And I think they give false information. But it doesn't mean that you don't have a virus. So that being said, should you then treat the virus?
Well, by all means, you should treat your body, whatever you're not feeling well and try to stimulate your immune system to be able to kill this stuff.
So absolutely, you should be taking care of me. Do I believe COVID was real? Absolutely. There was, I believe was a real virus that it was dangerous to a lot of people.
But how they treated in hospitals was criminal. I think there should be, you know, a million doctors and nurses jail right now.
I think that the powers that be that forced them forced their head to do what they did, one of them did it, not letting you to do it, but still that doesn't give you an excuse for doing something that's wrong.
So that being said, there's a lot of natural things you could do for viruses or flus or colds and bacterial infections.
We have a lot of stuff on our blog post still there too.